that we will have is about increasing
vaccine confidence obviously highlighted
as one of the major challenges facing
facing us in this era of fake news and
social media and we're going to explore
it in two phases
the initial phase will be discussions
about increasing vaccine confidence ways
to do it challenges we face and the
second one is more about how we can
disseminate better information
fact-based information some rules of the
game I have a huge panel of amazing
people so I have asked all our panelists
to stay on message and to keep to about
three three to four minutes so we can
proceed well I am the moderator but I am
privileged to have Commissioner Andrew
Curtis Commissioner for health and food
safety of the European Commission
so Commissioner you are the chair but in
a role reversal I'm actually a boss I
will give you the floor so and give you
and you know you will set the agenda for
for this meeting so on my panel very
very happy to have Maggie two-block
Minister for Social Affairs in public
health and asylum and migration of
Belgium thank you very much for being
here Maggie
professor Leticia respects is President
World Federation of Public Health
associations a vice admiral Jerome Adams
Surgeon General of the United States I'm
being very rude and very brief about
introducing our amazing panelists but
you do have their biographies and I
don't want to take up too much time but
we know that all of you are here because
you represent and you speak in very
important ways Kate O'Brien there you
are
director immunization vaccines and
biologicals from the w-h-o thank you
very much
then then we're going to have a special
video message
it's from Beatrice view she's Italian
wheelchair fencer and world champion and
para Olympic champion she couldn't be
here today she's actually on her way to
Seoul for another championship on
wheelchair fencing so she has sent us a
video message and then we'll continue
the conversation here we have Heidi
Larsen director of the vaccine
confidence project mode sack a public
policy manager Mozilla there you are not
and have to say at least but last but
not least
hi Jason Jason Hurst Public Policy
Manager Facebook lovely to have all of
you here commissioner your three minutes
start now thank you thank you so much
first of all let me tell you I am so
happy to see big full of like-minded
friends you know thank you very much
indeed for coming being together because
now I think we can call all of us that
we are united forces for vaccination
against fake news against vaccine
hesitancy we need to understand now we
are not here to preach each other no
because we are like-minded here but
because they have live stream you know
opportunity
consent message to all around the
European Union and to all around the
world well as now is time to act and to
act based on sons to build trust to be
honest and of course to to send message
about humanism because vaccines save
lives but on not only they read a real
example of humanism altruism and
possibility to to to see better and
safer world around the globe for us now
it's real time every minute we do not
act cost lives of children every minute
and we need to understand today now how
it is important for all of us to join
forces and to organize the first global
summit and then to see to speak about
next second global summit of course we
know very well we need we need to do
more in Europe because we have here a
big raise of vaccine hesitancy it's
really challenging situation when I see
figures from Dellen speak about for
example malnutrition of children or you
know children problems with nutritional
issues in one hand you see obesity in
European continent and malnutrition
in Africa and this is so complex picture
of complex you know issues and now
speaking about hesitancy in you have
very high rates of residence but not
enough taken Africa different things it
means that we need to have
multi-sectorial teams but focusing on
issues which are on the ground and of
the continent in every region and to see
how can we prepare ourselves to
communicate to just join forces to help
each other and of course to see what can
we do in the future to be more effective
and to overcome such distrust because
this trust in science this trust in
humanity that is a problem
sorry being so a little bit emotional
but I can
stop here because I like to see people
to listen to you and then only after two
to save some few words thank you once
again and welcome the summit and let's
do our best
Commissioner it's very important to be
emotional because in today's world we
all know facts matter but facts don't
aren't enough so your emotion your
humanity I think is very very important
so thank you for bringing it into the
debate and I would encourage all of you
to learn and do the same thing speak
from your heart and and let's
communicate in that way so a minister
and negative block I'm going to turn to
you and you know during this morning's
discussions we were told by Chaka Chaka
and others that it's also what access
it's not just about mothers not wanting
to do it to vaccinate the children but
it's also the vaccination services are
perhaps not there when they should be so
can I have some of your ideas on that
thank you and I won't be singing today
so you can be sure he's so indeed
successful vaccination it began already
in 1796 with a cow pox vaccination by
Edward Jenner and then we had a famous
Louis Pasteur who introduced new
vaccines so who would have thought in
those days that two decades later or
three decades later there would be
people who would say that there were no
benefits of vaccination and we would put
in doubt the need to vaccination so of
course it is a fact that people have
become less acquainted with the
complications and the consequences of
the disease available by vaccination and
so now we have generations that don't
know people anymore dying of the
complications of for example of
poliomyelitis of or
measles so to strengthen accessible
vaccinations services I would like to
answer two simple questions why does not
have who does not have vaccinations
access to vaccinations and why is that
that is the first question and which
actions are most likely to improve
vaccination access so first of all who
does not have access to vaccination
services in Belgium we have a diverse
offer of services to provide
vaccinations to several target groups so
for young people we have the well-baby
clinics and school health services
provide the vaccinations for school
children in addition to this population
based approach parents can at any time
address other services like the general
petitioners or the pediatrician where
vaccinate as vaccines are already there
and they can be given also free of
charge next to these services or social
security system from specific
organizations like the doctors of the
world that help people without health
insurance and specific health care is
organized also for the asylum seekers as
a Sun seekers are offered vaccinations
the first day the day of their arrival
before dispatching and are followed in
the reception centers so accepting
vaccinations is of course not obligated
nevertheless there are few or almost
none asylum seekers seekers who refuse
to be vaccinated the inclusive approach
results in a high vaccination rate of
more than 95 percent for the first dose
of vaccination against measles but also
we had a recent outbreak of measles in
2017 and it was mainly in the
french-speaking part and in Brussels so
such outbreaks are probably due to the
fact that we have still groups or
growing groups of people that haven't
being vaccinated because they refused to
do so that is in our country that is the
problem as we heard from other countries
there are other reasons why there is no
not enough access so we do should not
only vaccinate take action to vaccinate
your children but we also need to take
targeted measures to improve vaccination
rate among adults and then we see where
population-based actions are possible
the vaccination rate is much higher for
example institutions that provide care
for elderly people we do the flu
vaccination like that and the rate is 82
percent in Flanders so in Belgium people
are not vaccinated are mainly people who
to do circumstances have not been
vaccinated by any of these initiatives
that I've been telling about all refused
to be vaccinated due to wrong
information by the anti vaccination
movements and I would also also like to
stress the importance of the follow-up
so you have the first vaccination with
the babies and then you also have to do
the follow-up vaccinations during
childhood but also during the adult life
so the vaccinations rate is often then a
lot lower in these groups that are then
or that are a very young age and
follow-up vaccinations require also more
focused attention so to conclude I can
say that making vaccines and
vaccinations financially accessible is
not enough we need outreach and targeted
actions to reach a vaccination rate that
protects the entire community so the
second question I think it's important
to consider what actions or politics
policies are most likely to improve
vaccinations access and I support the
idea to launch a social social movement
for vaccination these social movements
should reinforce vaccinations as a
social norm this can be done in sir
we can equip health professionals to
communicate effectively with parents
about vaccines but we should use all
opportunities when patients come into
contact with our health system and for
the first time that is of course at the
birth so we could also engage sort of
health advocates patients academics
civic organizations to praise
vaccinations and to present Pro
vaccinations arguments and stories in
popular soaps for example or sitcoms we
could encourage role models we could
teach children in schools about
importance the scientific background and
a successful global impact of
vaccination on a civilized society and
the city of Brussels will introduce
objective information on the subject in
the first year and school in the lessons
of biology and that could have also an
important influence on the vaccinations
of the girls against cervical cancer so
I would like to stress the importance of
educating health professionals during
their training and on-the-job because
also health professionals have to be
vaccinated and it takes too long before
physicians recognize for example the
symptoms of measles if you don't know
zebra you don't know what it is so that
that can allow the disease to spread
even more so to conclude I would like to
stress that political commitment is
essential I'm glad there are so many
people here today
and today there are 16 million people
who can walk because vaccines protecting
them against polio so never forget that
immunizations saves lives vaccines save
lives thank you
thank you very much indeed Minister I
could just thank you very much indeed
and I really enjoyed your reference to
social movement that has to be created I
think that's one of in our in our modern
world as we say that's one of the areas
where we need to force the issue thank
you very much
panelists you do not all have to stand
up I mean it's your option if you want
to you're welcome to do so
if you don't you don't have to do so but
thank you very much Minister Leticia if
I could just turn to you and Minister
Magda block did talk about towards the
end of the need to equip and train
health professionals because one of the
things you see is that people are
sometimes mothers I guess our are
sometimes a bit afraid and don't ask the
right questions and tend to be
intimidated a little bit by health
professionals so what's your what's your
opinion on that this yes good morning I
would like to greet all of you I'm from
South Africa so I would like to greet
you in one of our languages which is san
bonanni and what it means is I see you
and you see me and we recognize each
other's common humanity so I have
exactly three minutes and I have three
key messages one for each of the minutes
that I have so the the first my brief
was to talk about the role of health
professionals or health care providers
so my first message is that health
professionals should use every
opportunity during pregnancy and in a
winner in contact with children in the
first six years of life to discuss
vaccination so the Commissioner talked
about at birth but I think at birth it
might be to a too late and pregnancy
allows us whether we in low or middle
income countries or high-income
countries to actually broach the subject
of exhalation with caregivers or
appearance the second message that I
have is that as health professionals and
I'm one myself we have to
learn certain assumptions that we have
and two of the assumptions that I think
we have to unlearn are one that parents
are ignorant and secondly that parents
do not have the best interest of their
children at heart so that's my second
message the importance of unlearning
some of the assumptions that we have and
the third aspect that I think should be
stressed both during pre-service
education before we go into the into the
services as undergraduate students as
well as during continuing professional
development is the importance of
communication and rather than talking
down to to caregivers or community
members and giving them instructions so
what are some of the aspects that I
think we should stress during either
pre-service education or during
continuing professional development
firstly it's the importance of trust we
all know that communities number of
studies have shown that communities are
much more likely to trust health
professionals then for example
politicians and I apologize to the
politicians in the room but that's a
that's effect the the importance of of
listening the willingness to listen to
the parents I do think it's not a one
size fits all so we have to learn to
tailor our communication to where
caregivers are ayat so for example try
and find out way that the the the parent
or the caregiver is is it somebody who
accepts who's a child or children's
vaccinations vaccinations are up to date
sits somebody who is maybe more cautious
or hesitant or somebody who's refusing
it try and find out what are the reasons
why they might be at that particular
position you know try and find
out what what are some of the aspects
that might make them change their mind
give them the opportunity to go back and
to to come back with questions and point
them to credit a credible information
systems I think all health professionals
should also be exposed to the model that
the w-h-o developed recently with a
group of experts which is increasing
vaccination model it shows the complex
process of decision making that parents
go through before they decide on
vaccination and is both a process that
involves what you feel and what you
think it's the contact that you come
into which influences your motivation
but it's also some of the factors that
influence whether you're actually going
to take your child for vaccination so if
the opening hours if you are working
parent and the health facility or
vaccination is only provided during
office hours you less likely to kind of
go there go there if the health
professional is rude and doesn't listen
to you you less likely to actually go
there so what are the factors that
influence convenience and of course
lastly as I said again the opportunity
to give caregivers and parents the the
opportunity to come back with additional
questions be righter than feel that
they've been ambushed
into a vaccination that they do not want
thank you very much
thank you very much Leticia so focusing
very much on trust and building empathy
and an understanding
Vice Admiral also Leticia talked about
tailor-made interventions and from your
experience Surgeon General of the United
States how important is it to reach to
the subgroups of vulnerable people those
who are perhaps more vulnerable to
distant formation what are you doing
about those things
well bones roaring good morning again
I'm Jerome Adams the United States
Surgeon General and we heard from the
esteemed princess of Africa this morning
I'm known as the doctor of America and I
want all of you all to know that as the
doctor of America I firmly believe in
the vaccinations very the greatest
public health intervention of the last
50 years in the United States and I'll
give you some statistics to prove that
we've got 1,200 cases of measles in the
US and 2019 and we see that as a failure
we see that as a failure but we have to
remember that in 1963 the number of
measles cases each and every year in the
United States was three to four million
so we've had tremendous success via
vaccinations but I want to hit on an
important point it's critical that we're
all here together as the Commissioner
mentioned because when you look at the
outbreaks in the United States measles
is not endemic in the United States the
measles cases are being brought in when
people travel to other countries and so
all of us are interdependent in this
relationship and another important point
it's easy to get caught up in the bad
statistics but confidence and hesitancy
are two sides of the same coin and I
think we have to be careful here because
those who oppose vaccines when when we
feed into the narrative that going
unvaccinated is the new norm so I want
you to know that in the United States
actually 93 percent of US adults are
getting their kids vaccinated 93 percent
of people are doing the right thing
so our real challenge is to dig into
that seven percent who aren't and among
those folks a large majority of them are
still having problems with access I
won't go into that because it was laid
out perfectly what we need to do but we
need to remember that all that 7% a lot
of those folks still don't have back
and then there are folks who are
hesitant who need to get the right
information at the right time to make
the best decisions for their young
people and then finally there are people
who are resistant and they're loud
they're loud but they really are the
minority of the minority and we need to
remember that I want to get into the
question in the u.s. we have a pockets
of unvaccinated people who cluster in
certain geographic areas and they create
vulnerabilities in our national defense
against vaccine preventable diseases so
we've seen in the u.s. that our
outbreaks often occur in close knit
communities the Orthodox Jewish
community in New York City and New York
State the Amish community in Ohio the
Somali community and Minnesota that are
insulated and don't trust external
information sources and in some cases
these communities have been targeted
with misinformation from other other
people who were spreading bad news on
vaccines but I have some good news for
you as you may have heard the New York
City outbreak which began in October has
been officially declared as over there
were over 600 cases but uh we tackled
that and we tackled that folks want to
know what the secret sauce was well it's
engagement of community organizations
and local leaders in New York City it
was it was working with the rabbi that
was realizing that the people who don't
get vaccinated they don't follow the
Surgeon General on Twitter and so we
need to make sure we're working with
those faith leaders those local radio
stations those community groups that
really help us get to the people who
most need to be vaccinated very quickly
our plan in the u.s. is to increase
access to vaccinations to use data
technology and resources to identify
pockets of low vaccination rates and to
work with all partners to decrease the
spread of bad information I wouldn't be
doing my job if I didn't point out
disparities in our efforts to restore
health equity we know that minorities we
know that people who live in rural areas
like Ethan who you're going to hear from
later have lower vaccination rates than
their white than their urban
counterparts we know that black Hispanic
and Asian adults have lower vaccination
rates compared to their white peers and
therefore we see increased rates of
hepatitis HPV and tetanus in those
communities so health equity
and uncovering the disparities are
important in those situations and I want
to finish just by highlighting a couple
of efforts that we're working on we're
working with Twitter with Pinterest with
Facebook and with Instagram and you're
gonna hear from those folks later so I
won't talk about their initiatives but
it's key that we get to where the
misinformation is being spread and we're
not going to solve this problem by
waiting for people to come into our
offices into our clinics and say give me
the information we need to get to where
they are and spread appropriate
information and then finally I want to
highlight that US health secretary a
czar was pleased to join with you
Commissioner Andrew Titus and ministers
from Brazil and Canada to highlight the
challenges of promoting vaccine
confidence at the World Health Assembly
earlier this year and we're looking
forward to working together on a joint
resolution because we all all of us
should be able to stand up together and
loudly say that vaccines are one of the
greatest public health interventions
that we have available and that we all
need to make sure we're protecting the
people of this planet by promoting them
so thank you very much
thank you very much Vice Admiral for
giving us the state of play in the u.s.
at the moment we do here some rather
alarming information here as you know
and the importance of reaching out not
waiting for people to come all of this
is very very good advice that I'm sure
we're all very happy to hear thank you
very much indeed
Kate turn to you we've been talking I
mean it's only been about a few hours
that we've been into the discussion but
a lot about partnership and working
together so from your perspective how
dude decision makers corporates industry
civic society how can we all join forces
and work for vaccine confidence I'm so
pleased to be able to make a few remarks
especially coming after being set up so
well by the remarks that have already
been made I speak both as a pediatrician
I'm a mother and I've worked in many
countries around the world I think was
the first thing we have to know is that
vaccine hesitancy or antibac says not a
new phenomenon we have had anti backs
misinformation
since the time we've had vaccines what's
really new is the opportunity for those
messages to spread as far and wide in as
quickly as they do now and that calls on
us for bold action for us to counter
those messages and assure that we're
partnering together we're working
together to assure that we're bringing
all of our best practices or information
forward so that we all have the
opportunity to benefit vaccine
confidence issues are not issues only
about high-income countries this is
impacting immunization programs in many
countries around the world to a larger
or to a lesser degree and I think we
have to really look to the future as
well this issue is not going to go away
and as we look at demographics and we
look at the projections for how social
media will be even further distributed
in the future we really have to be
thinking about who are the parents of
tomorrow and what are they being
influenced by today and how can we
respond we've seen major issues around
nation in many different countries
around the world that includes as was
mentioned by the director-general that
includes pakistan dr congo very serious
issues but it also includes
middle-income countries Brazil the
Philippines and these are widely
distributed in terms of what that what
the underlying issues are that means
that action has to take place at all
levels it means that we all have to step
in ahead on this we have to lean forward
on what each of the agencies which each
of the partners can actually do to to
take action against this there's a key
rule obviously for w-h-o and part of
that role is coordination when we're
talking to each other we actually get
greater leverage of the actions and
information that we have so that we're
not working in silos the strategic
advisory group of experts has provided
recommendations on what we should be
doing what we should be measuring how we
should be monitoring this I really
firmly believe that you can't fix what
you can't measure and this is one
particular issue in vaccine confidence
is that we have difficulty as an entire
community knowing how to measure this
what does it mean when someone says that
they may lack some confidence does that
actually translate to how they act so
this is an area that certainly needs
more more clarity there's a very
important role for civil society for
medical associations pediatric
associations religious leaders as was
just commented on where decisions are
made and where parents are influenced is
at a very local level and so that's
where our interventions really have to
take place and it's about working in
very tailored circumstances to
understand what the particular situation
is in that particular community that's
driving the issue around either failing
to choose to get vaccines or inability
to access them so jointly developing
sort of evidence on information
developing plans
and an action approach really means
people centered design that local
evidence has to be specifically tailored
and it has to be multi-dimensional there
is no one fix to this issue it calls on
social media it calls on health care
worker training it calls on the ability
of programs to provide services that
people want to go get that they have a
positive experience when they actually
go to get the services and they actually
get vaccines when they're there all of
these things reinforce vaccine
confidence and resilience among families
parents and other people to
misinformation or messages that are
quite confusing to them so this
investment in improvements in service
quality in primary health care and of
course universal health coverage are
essential to make the progress that we
need I want to sort of end by just
reinforcing that the underpinning of all
of this is our ability to understand
what's happening unless we have an
understanding of what's happening in
communities and can actually measure and
monitor and then act through
well-designed actions that we take
together we're really kind of running
blind so this is an area of emphasis
that that we would make in in sort of
the action the partnership among
institutions and among all sectors to to
make our way forward it's all in there
Thanks
thank you very much so understanding
what's happening sharing information
best practices not just as conferences
such as this but also in our daily
interactions I think that's very very
good advice thank you very much indeed
so I had promised you a video with
Beatriz
veal and I was wondering if we could see
it now
she's the wheelchair fencer champion
please so sorry that I cannot be there
now actually but because I'm out for
other stuff but just introduce me baby
I'm 22 years old and I think I'm fencing
when I was five years old like Senna
fencing but then due to like meningitis
so it's like the like a disease the
doctor has to amputee like both my life
in my arms I just part of my body but
now I get processes I began again with
fencing which were fencing obviously and
now we are doing like a lot of stuff as
like we create an oral no profit
association and we are trying to help
all the guys with amputation to do
sparta bind them like process these
wheelchairs or crutches and all so just
to say I am super happy actually I'm a
peep for everything we are work a lot
for all I've been all the other guy
but the problem was that I didn't I
didn't do that vaccine when I was when I
was younger and due to I thought that I
did not the vaccine I had this
this is but there's the vaccine so what
I'm saying now and what all my family is
trying to to tell to everybody is just
try to do the vaccine and just if you
don't want to do the vaccine just
straight to be a really informative out
about it and do a lot of research and
try to talk to some doctors and that's a
my obviously my my tips is to do the
best fit but just do some information so
that's it thank you everybody
and see you soon bye thank you very much
I mean I think this message is like
thieves are powerful messages from
younger people Commission I think you'll
agree resonate so much right what a
personal experience and what a brave
brave young lady she is actually young
women are the leaders in today's world I
mean everywhere I think we have to agree
and support that thank you very much for
the organizers for bringing her in
through video very moving and let's move
on and let's talk to Heidi Larson so
Heidi from the morning onwards we've
heard about fake news disinformation
misinformation anti-vaxxers getting so
much a platform and Vice Admiral said
it's loud but it's a minority so I was
just wondering from your angle what are
you doing to bring this debate into fact
rather than sliding further into fiction
I don't know oh that yes since working
loud and clear
good morning I'm Heidi Larson and I lead
the vaccine confidence project it's a
research group I set up ten years ago
now having worked with UNICEF and and in
the field around the world and saw the
emerging issues and the one thing when I
was trying to build some strategies
around that the question that kept
coming back was just stick to the
positive stuff
this is margins margins margins unless
you can measure it it's not going to be
taken seriously so I left UNICEF and set
up a research group basically to think
about measuring
and monitoring it globally since then
and that was initially online monitoring
we've developed a confidence index that
is one piece of a broader group of
measurements we need we need much more
in-depth but to get the finger on the
pulse of sentiment both here in the EU
we've done two rounds and we'll
hopefully continue both here and
globally and the first global confidence
index we ran in 2016 I knew there were
issues but I was really surprised at the
extent to which Europe was the least
confident country and the world France
actually won the prize but the
importance is the repetitions of that
the Wellcome Trust we just collaborated
with the Wellcome Trust on a global
study on trust and confidence in health
and safety health and science and France
again had the least confidence in the
world and some of the media said but
it's dropped so much and I said wait a
minute
it's actually up 10 points from two
years ago
so that shows the importance of you
can't say things have dropped because we
don't really know where they were
we weren't really asking and we're just
starting to create an environment of
consciousness about it I think if
someone asked me what's the biggest
contribution that's happened in the last
decade I think we understand it we are
by looking around the room this could
have never happened a decade ago if I
could have gotten or my colleagues in
the UN could have gotten 12 people in
the room on this topic this speaks to
the importance of the issues and the
acknowledgement of it I think we it's
important and as Freud says until you
have a acknowledged e of a problem you
can't do anything about it so good start
I think one of the things that I the
question I was asked was to speak say a
few words on is the role of traditional
media and scientific publications well
traditional is pretty old and that's not
the world we live in
so traditional is now virtually all
online even the billboards that are on
highways than around end up on YouTube
end up so we need to look at the broader
online environment not just the social
media but the reality that anything you
do whether you're sitting in the Amish
community well maybe not there because
there's not a lot of YouTube going on
but but but these things travel we saw
with the Orthodox community that jumped
in northern London to Antwerp to other
similar communities around the world
Israel we need to look at the Cascade of
information we've heard from a number of
people about the multi-faceted aspects
of this this issue and how we cannot
just pick on one thing I think from the
scientific publications perspective we
have a lot of responsibility from the
ethics behind it Andrew Wakefield
in 1998 who wrote the famous now
infamous paper suggesting links between
the MMR vaccine and autism was not
debunked because they didn't agree with
his conclusion they lost he lost his
credentials because of it's unethical
procedure in his research in science
science is about asking questions
science is about uncertainty and there's
one big challenge we have moving forward
which makes defining in misinformation
and information the world is not divided
that way with vaccination we have a lot
of uncertainty between what we can
confidently say this is fact and what we
can confidently say this is not this is
misinformation so one of my points is
that issues around we we should slow
down in the disproportionate focus on
misinformation
I think it's overly focused on because
this is a much bigger this is about
emotions the billboards
our smattering different corners of the
world from Australia to Romania Italy
the US and in other countries these
billboards are not saying anything
illegal
many of the facebook pages are not
saying anything that you can confidently
say is misinformation
they are instilling doubt they are
provoking questions they are creating a
population that doesn't trust the
billboards say do you really know what's
in a vaccine that's not illegal we care
about you you know you should have a
choice this is something that's way
beyond misinformation so let's not lose
the plot by focusing on infamous
information we cannot legally or
ethically remove it from any information
the UN office of Human Rights got
extremely concerned has become extremely
concerned about the growing efforts and
focus on trying to rein it in online the
misinformation and they extra convened
an extraordinary committee and a report
or on the ethics of limiting on on
different social media platforms what
can be said and what cannot
they are extremely worried that the kind
of raining and we're doing with hate
with anti sentiments on different areas
is a red carpet for authoritarian
governments to abuse that privilege we
have some serious work to do my work in
UNICEF was largely in human rights we
have a lot of work to do in thinking
about the human rights of how we're
handling this where the limits of the
right of the individual and the
responsibilities the right of the
individual and the right of the public
to health the freedom of expression and
yet the right to privacy this is not a
small topic and this needs a much bigger
discussion my last point and this is
already been mentioned and with our
thankfully emotion
opening which is what we need more than
ever on the positive front not just on
the negative is the issue of trust and
resilience the reason people are
gobbling up this misinformation and
questioning is because the trust and the
resilience is eroding we need to work on
that and we've heard it in different
ways from everyone I think the comment
on the the distrust and humanism is
absolutely important and raises the
point that this these this distrust is
not just about vaccines we are living in
an acutely distrusting environment and
my view is vaccines can lead the way it
touches every individual on the planet
if we can get it right for vaccines
we're doing a lot for the trust in the
world
Thank You Heidi thank you for the words
of caution I think very well received
very important but also the linkage with
the other trust and chaos and confusion
issue that is a geopolitical landscape
at the moment
thank you very much more to come back to
the responsibility of social media let's
hear from you on what is being done and
what is being planned to be done
thank you very much sue good morning
everyone my name is MOT sake I represent
Mozilla today very quickly Mozilla is
the organisation behind the Firefox web
browser that's a product that is but is
used by a hundreds of millions of people
across the world to answer your question
I think and to echo very much what has
been said just before this information
is very very complex problem that
includes many different areas of tech
policy between privacy free speech
platform liability these are debates
we've been having in Europe for quite a
few years now and that we will probably
continue to have with a new mandate of
the Commission and these are very very
complicated complicated topic that needs
a lot of neurons however we think it's
clear but although the Internet is only
one factor among many about in the way
people make that decision as to whether
they want to be vaccinated or not social
media and internet marginally plays a
role
either in reducing or increasing public
anxiety about these issues and so we
believe that platforms have actually
responsibility to ensure that people at
least are not manipulated by bad content
online and of course the entire debate
is how can that you can be done in a way
that we think acceptable in a democratic
society generally speaking the way a lot
of content platform and social media
work mainly this day
is that they prioritize viewer
engagement rather than accuracy of
information and the wage return I mean
these are at advertising based platform
our attention attention driven which
means that usually the content that is
sensational is the one that is given
priority over content whether is maybe I
create a scientifically accurate but is
less exciting I would say usually
generated less views at Mozilla we are
very much engaged in the fight against
this information we are a signatory of a
code of practice on this information
that has been done by the EU Commission
this complements the work that we can do
as a browser we've been investing in
technology and tools and research to
fight this information and that actually
is linked to our commitment to an
Internet
but elevates critical thinking and
verifiable facts and so what kind of
practice was a very good step we've
reformed but we still think more needs
to be done and we think there are
several measures that could be taken to
fight against with symptoms of
disinformation and at least I call one
of the problem but what is as a root of
this information if I take with symptoms
we think that ways at least were four
platforms you look at how to tweak a bit
there recommendation engines to ensure
that content that the spread of that
kind of content is at least reduced
doesn't spread as widely as it can be
done today there's of course work
regarding false accounts and BOTS that
can create some kind of false
amplification around was debate and
critically from Mozilla point of view
ways perhaps more transparency regarding
the advertisement on a platforms that
could be that could be important and
specifically for the anti-vaccination
campaign the wrong issue base
we think it's important to try to have
more information bit more data to
identify who is trying to influence
people and who is benefiting from both
campaign that could be an area to try to
better understand and to better fight
against that phenomenon and I'll
conclude with what we consider to be one
of the roots of the problems and that is
for us online tracking very simply put
more creator of this information know
about you the more they can precisely
target message to you and that is why
much like has so much about reducing
online tracking this is why we build
tools to protect users online against
online tracking and that is why data
protection is so important for us and so
to conclude we also think that
systematic enforcement of the general
data protection regulation the name
now-famous gdpr could actually minimize
some of its tracking and micro targeting
of people online and and could help and
to fight against this information thank
you
thank you very much so Jason actually
the same question to you responsibility
and what is Facebook doing to tackle
this challenge sure thank you and thanks
to the w-h-o and the commission for
having us here
I share the commissioner's passion for
this subject as we do as a company and
we really appreciate the opportunity and
are very grateful for the chance to
participate and be collaborative with
this group it's really important to
everything that we want to accomplish in
the health space and the vaccine space
specifically in terms of of what we can
do to improve the quality of information
about vaccinations on our platform and
what we are doing I think it's important
to start with what dr. Ted Rose talked
about this morning and the importance of
partnership this is an issue that we
take very seriously but we ourselves of
course are not health experts at
Facebook so we have spent the better
part of the last nine months working
very hard with lots of the organizations
that are represented here today to learn
to collaborate and this is a great
opportunity for us to continue doing
that today
and through the course of that
collaboration what we have seen is that
we want to take a two-part approach to
improving the quality of information
about vaccinations on our platform the
first thing that we are doing is
reducing the distribution of
misinformation about vaccinations and
the second thing that we're doing is
increasing exposure to credible
authoritative content about vaccinations
and so let me just walk folks through
both parts of that and what we're doing
I think on reducing distribution as dr.
O'Brien said earlier misinformation
about vaccinations is not new it goes
back to the middle of the 19th century
what's new is the ability for it to
spread and so we've tried to focus on
how to limit its spread as opposed to
stopping it altogether and so as of
March of this year on Facebook we have a
new policy which is rooted
in the work of many of the organizations
that are here today and for hoaxes about
vaccinations claims that have been
debunked by consensus of expert
organizations like w-h-o and Gavi and
UNICEF things like vaccines cause autism
we when we find those claims on Facebook
we there are a series of consequences
now for posting them if you are a
Facebook group or a Facebook page who
repeatedly post this type of debunked
information about vaccinations we will
reduce the distribution of not just
those posts but everything that you post
to ensure that we are being
appropriately comprehensive and
aggressive in trying to reduce the
spread of this kind of information
likewise if you're one of those groups
or pages that's posting this information
you will be reduced in facebook search
results so that when people search for
things about vaccinations your group or
page won't be one of the first things
that comes up you will also if you are
one of the entities that repeatedly
spreads this kind of information be
removed from all of our recommendation
engines across Facebook so your content
won't be content that we suggest to
other users
we've talked a little about advertising
so when it comes to advertising any
advertisement that contains and this
information about vaccinations will be
rejected on Facebook . in addition we
have removed a number of targeting terms
terms that advertisers can use to target
folks that have been lending themselves
to anti vaccination type themes in
advertising and lastly pages on facebook
have the ability to fundraise on their
page but if you're a page that posts
misinformation about vaccinations you
get stripped of that ability so that's
the reduced distribution of the negative
misinformation content but at the same
time we recognize as Heidi explained
that there is a vast middle ground of
content that is not necessarily
misinformation
but that can otherwise be problematic in
this space and the best way to combat
that and frankly the misinformation as
well is to ensure that we are elevating
authoritative content to users across
Facebook and so as some people may know
last week we launched a new effort in
collaboration with specifically the
w-h-o and the CDC but more broadly with
the insights of many other groups who
are here today
educational units that will appear on
Facebook in a variety of places in at
the top of search results that are about
vaccinations in invitations to join
Facebook groups that discuss vaccines on
Facebook pages that discuss vaccines and
on Instagram where hashtags are related
to vaccines we will have educational
units that that provide users with a few
sentences about the w-h-o and the CDC's
view on why vaccines are important and
where authoritative information exists
and then links out to the w-h-o and the
CDC's website so that users can get more
information and authoritative
information when they have questions
because as as lots of folks have talked
about today hesitancy exists and a lot
of different kinds of people for a lot
of different reasons and in the months
that it took us to put these educational
units together among the things we
learned were that people who are
hesitant wanna feel legitimized in the
questions that they have empathy goes a
long way and ultimately what they really
crave is access to information and
sometimes the hesitancy stems from the
inability to access that information and
so they're swayed by the wrong kinds of
information and so the goal of these
educational units is to ensure that we
invite people who are using Facebook
into a dialogue and send them to places
like the WH o--'s website so that we
ensure that the dialogue they're having
and the information that they're getting
is high quality and so now as of this
week that has rolled out globally in a
variety of languages we will
continue to roll out these educational
units in more languages over the coming
few weeks so that users across Facebook
whatever they whatever information they
may encounter about vaccinations the
goal is that the first thing they
encounter in most of the key places
where users go will be science-based
authoritative credible information about
vaccines and so we're very grateful to
the collaboration with many of the folks
here that has gotten us this far and we
look forward to continued to
collaboration as we seek to improve our
efforts over time thank you thank you
very much so reassuring comments and
interventions from our panelists as well
about steps that are being taken and
steps that are being planned as well so
I think we are on the right track but of
course we need to see the proof of the
pudding as it were in the eating so
thank you very much indeed I was just
wondering if someone is tracking our
hashtags how are we doing on social
media at the moment can someone are we
doing well are we trending okay so guys
thank you very much for all your passion
I haven't been able to tweet or put
things on Facebook Jason today because
I'm busy doing other things but I will
do so as well tomorrow later this
afternoon so thank you for doing that I
have time for a few questions from the
floor but I need to turn back very
quickly to the parents because I have an
overarching question and of course
Commissioner as well so could I just see
two two maybe three quick comments from
the floor and I was wondering if the
Hungarian Minister of Health is is in
the room there you are Hungary's
Minister of State Hungary is doing
rather well in vaccine coverage right
just a few words please thank you very
much we're working on it
we assume that the the vaccines changed
to human history while smallpox killed
some further half of the nations now
kiss nobody since there we have a number
300 we have a hundred year
history of mandatory vaccination process
in Hungary and it means that at the
moment it's like 13 vaccinations type
and for all of them we have a coverage
of vaccine coverage close to a hundred
percent meaning this is 99% this needs a
lot of third we have a system we have a
network of very well trained health care
professionals we call them in Hungarian
we do new which is defender has defender
health protector they are were trained
to save the life of mothers and children
and trained very well how to keep very
close contact with the families to
ensure that they trust information and
they accept the vaccine scheme and this
is crucial for us that it works like
that and another 100 is that therefore
the public trust is close to 100% is
always above 93 95 percent we are very
happy to share anything what we do with
anybody here and we wish a great success
in this fight so probably the 21st
century is really going to be something
where we can eliminate measles we can
emulate hepatitis and so on so forth
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed for that comment
it's a between Ian Minister here as well
and maybe perhaps share some comments
I'm here okay thank you for those
brilliant comments and it's two feelings
that comes to my heart by listening in
in one hand Lithuania is expanding
number of vaccines that is more and more
available to the society and we
introduced meningitis B and HPV vaccines
so more and more of our society and
children could be protected by by
vaccines from different diseases but in
other hand we are facing the same
challenges as we have mentioned the
vaccine resistance which is not big but
it's very loud and and I completely
agree with you with those who have
mentioned that in fact I'm
medical doctor myself and I know that
the patients are mostly trusting doctors
not the politicians so when we talk very
loudly from the political point of view
it doesn't really necessary builds the
trust to the vaccines so we are looking
for the ways how to motivate the medical
doctors and family physicians to discuss
those issues with the patients with the
young parents and you have mentioned
correctly we have to start early from
the pregnant women to discuss those
issues and I'm very very sure that we we
can find the solution and we really need
the international support and I'm very
happy to see the Facebook representative
here I just posted the hashtag to my
Facebook account and I see what the
comments are coming you know the the
people that are motivated to vaccinate
they don't comment they don't follow me
those who are hesitant they immediately
appear and they are asking questions so
so this sometimes creates a misleading
picture that people are against which is
not true because they are very few so we
have to work together we we have to look
to the good examples and thanks to the
colleague from Hungary I definitely will
look to your experience of those
professionals who works with the society
so thank you for this conference thank
you very much indeed
just a second Weiss Admiral I just need
a couple more intuitions and I just come
back to you do you want to come back
just on that yes go ahead very quickly
to say quickly one of the the things we
need to do is to make sure we're giving
the people who are the influencers and
we can't assume that doctors nurses
pharmacists know how to talk to someone
and dispel vaccine misinformation so one
of the keys is giving people scripts and
CDC as
to make sure all doctors offices have
access to scripts to say when someone
questions you about vaccines this is the
information these are the facts when we
were in New York it was giving the
rabbi's the appropriate information to
have that conversation
it's really about identifying those key
influencers and giving them the tools
that they need to broker that
conversation could I have it on all the
time please yes thank you very much
I'd like to turn to the finished State
Secretary as well presidency of the EU
obviously you are pleased Minister short
and sweet thank you chair for allowing
me to make a brief intervention on
behalf of Finland vaccine coverage in
Finland remains high but we have certain
pockets of at-risk populations earlier
this year Finland published of national
report on improving vaccination
activities we explored options to
strengthen positive attitude States
vaccination of families and health
workers based on the principles of
voluntary vaccinations and fundamental
rights even if vaccines remain voluntary
some maternity benefits are dependent on
visit to maternal and child health
clinics the report proposed
comprehensive measures to improve
vaccination coverage through for further
improving the availability and
accessibility of maternity and child
health clinic services increasing
training of health professionals
improving communications strengthening
research and developing legislation
Finland is concerned about the
increasing misinformation and
disinformation in particular on vaccines
but also on health and science in
general communication strategies to both
the general public and healthcare
professionals
remain key levers in improving
vaccination coverage and vaccination
confidence but the truth is that public
campaigns are not enough we must improve
access to verified scientifically
trustworthy and up-to-date information
we applaud the decision by Facebook to
change their algorithms
so that search engines better direct
vaccine inquiries to public health pages
other the additional mechanisms that
would facilitate the recognition of
validated information such as certified
branding thank you thank you very much
minister for that intervention as well
it's the Minister of Norway here would
you like to say a few words please yes
thank you
vaccinations call raise rates for the
MMR vaccine and the hexavalent vaccine
among two-year-olds in Norway is at
nineteen six to nineteen seven percent
key elements of our national vaccination
policy are maintaining trust good
organization precise information and a
good vaccination registry data from the
National vaccination registry are
distributed to municipalities two times
a year to provide an overview of
unvaccinated children aged to eight
fifteen years
these children are then followed up to
ensure additional opportunities for
vaccination in addition we have an
online portal let's give people an
overview of the current vaccination
status based on data from the national
vaccine re registry thank you very much
indeed
state secretary of germany Thomas Stefan
please thank you and many thanks to the
panel for sharing your ideas with us I
totally agree with you that vaccines
trust and proper communication lines are
very important elements at the same time
I have to tell you that like others in
the room we have long experience in
trying to increase the confidence in our
country of the population but to be
honest we failed up to now to reach a
sufficient level of protection
the population we are close to the 95%
of vaccination rate but we are not yet
there and I also have to tell you that
after decades of trying again and again
to convince the population the federal
government has now issued a draft law
which also includes a legal obligation
to be vaccinated against measles it was
a difficult decision but we think it's
all about the protection of at least
some of the vulnerable members of the
society so it's an focused approach on
children because we think that parents
should be ensured that their children
are not endangered when they are sent to
schools to nurseries and other
institutions that is why the legal
obligation now covers the staff and the
children in those in those areas for the
first time and again coming back to what
you just said
it's a package of measures so we are not
just discussing the legal obligation at
the same time we want to enhance the
communication lines and the educational
side of the medal with the population so
we're also building up capacities in
that area and we are building up some
better surveillance mechanisms in the
country because at the end of the day
I'm very convinced with all the members
on the panel we are measured against the
outcome of our measures and this is we
should wipe out measles in the countries
and in Europe as a whole thank you Thank
You Minister we're just wondering if
Andra Amman is here yep there you go a
very short and sweet please yeah thank
you I'm the director of the European CDC
and
I just want to say what we are doing to
increase the confidence in vaccines and
I think it became clear from all the
interventions that we heard that there
is no one solution that fits all it has
to be tailored according to the
determinants in a country that may even
vary from vaccine to vaccine in the same
country and also to the different
epidemiological situations that these
determinants create now I believe there
are three things I mean there are many
things that we can do I want to mention
three one is I believe we have to change
the narrative the dominant discussion
nowadays is on vaccine safety and
effectiveness why these are very
important aspects we shouldn't forget
that the main reason why we have
vaccines is because they protect against
and they prevent serious and deadly
diseases and we see it in measles
I mean people die then you need to move
to your second point Andrea I'm really
sorry I need to give the flow back to
the prize the second point is we have
heard that health care workers are the
trusted sources and I also see that we
have to equip them with the tools that
they can deal with these questions so we
have developed a toolkit and we saw it's
not sufficient that we produce this in
English and translate it we have to
adapt it to the societal context in the
countries what you are doing last point
is we have to create a trusted source
for information so we are building in
line with the council recommendations
from last year a big scene information
portal for different with different
content for patients or general public
and for the for health care workers and
we want to launch it with a multilingual
content for the European in Malaysian
week next year next year great thank you
very much indeed thank you to all
interventions from the floor I want to
go back to the panel very very quickly
and then give the floor to a
commissioner at the end
you'd have to be very short and to the
points from your perspectives the
biggest challenge and how you're dealing
with it so let's start with mode your
biggest challenge really 30 seconds
please it's a very good question the
biggest challenge I think for us is you
understand technically what exactly is
going on on all the platforms and and
what are the range of more technical
measure but that can actually have a
most impact and can be the most and that
can be done very quickly I think from
the multi partner lens from W chose
lenses assuring that we have methods and
mechanisms that we can draw on all of
this experience and drive that so that
everybody benefits from it that we can
measure we know what's going on we know
where it's going on and why it's going
on so interventions can take place the
biggest challenge for health
professionals is to see community
members as they equals thank you very
much not you yet Commission Minister
please I think big challenges took if
the confidence to the patients in the
health workers and that we have to work
on by dialogue by information and by
mutual trust biggest challenge is too
many people think vaccine hesitancy is
the norm so when I say hash tag I need
you ought to say vaccines work
I am Vice Admiral Jerome Adams I'm here
at the global vaccination summit with
leaders from all across the world who
wants you to know that hashtag vaccines
work
going on Twitter at lunch break Heidi I
think the biggest challenge is the power
of belief one of the big things with
young mothers is the growing belief and
mother nature who we all believe in but
she some diseases she just can't fix so
I think the power of belief but I think
if we get some of the belief leaders on
board we're on the right path right I
think the biggest challenge for us is
understanding better how to engage our
users who are hesitant about
vaccinations we're on a path to improve
the quality of misinformation about
vaccinations and our demoting a lot of
it or elevating authoritative content we
want to make sure that people who have
questions feel like they can engage with
that content and want to engage with it
so that they get the good information
that folks in this room are putting out
there Commissioner I'm so happy to say
that in those minutes and hours I
learned a lot I don't know how you are
here but I learned a lot in this it
means lifelong learning concept is so
important because they have a really big
puzzle and from different different
angles now we see that we are even
capable really to create effective
coalition coalition united forces for
vaccination such as do you believe today
in this panel thank you very much'
standard my belief once again of course
I know very well we need to be very
accurate with information we should
respect all human rights for sure but of
course we need to do our best
analyzing situation and finding tools
and finding emotional sometimes you know
as well you know I have big debates in
Bulgaria two days ago because we have in
one hands the African swine fever
and three can kill a lot of pigs in
another we have lumpy skin disease but
we have vaccination healthy vaccinated
cows and stop the disease you know I
told you look cows are not against
vaccination that's good good shape picks
us us to provide you know effective
actions but we do not have and picks a
dying example and of course also
speaking about climate change situation
because now we are all of their
vulnerable around the globe no doubt and
it means that we need to have our you
know message cooperation coordination
and involvement and empowerment of
people people empowerment the part of
all societies and of course also very
dangerous phenomena is we know very well
that vaccines have side effect and some
are playing game the society
politicization of side effects it's very
challenging issue I saw a lot of you
know political campaigns when some
actors are using side effects
politicizing it and then they are
creating distrust once again and it's
very difficult science always is in
doubt but if you are politicizing is and
that it's very difficult we need to say
very clearly political will belief and
human rights can help us but
politicizing of problems is a very
dangerous way today thank you so much
thank you very much commissioner and
thank you also to all the panelists
could we give them another hand of
applause
I'd now like to invite all of you to
take your seats in the audience please
thank you so much for all your
interventions we've heard some very
important points today
I'm not going to summarize them because
we're short of time but we will have
reports later on thank you very much
indeed so now from the panel we move to
someone we've all heard of I'm really
happy to meet you Ethan yes I have you
all know the story of Eton Linda Berger
he is 18 years old are you still 18 okay
good school graduate and he's become a
vaccine advocate because of a very
personal story I'm not going to tell it
Ethan you are so could I ask you to
please come up here
[Applause]
huh well thank you for giving the
opportunity to speak and I'm glad that
you gave me an introduction usually when
I speak at a conference I'd to clarify
I'm not a child that wandered on stage
but I am obviously the youngest person
in this room that so far has spoken at
least and it's terrifying but I'm so
glad to have the opportunity so thank
you to everyone who's given me this
chance the European Commission w-h-o and
everyone else involved in making this
possible
see my presentation is fairly simple
because I'm not a scientist I don't run
a non-profit and in really every single
definition I'm just a normal kid despite
you know speaking here and honestly
before I get into all of that I actually
give you a very quick summary of my
story and it's fairly simple it's one
about a teenager who made an important
health decision that led to a massive
platform see I grew up in a household
where vaccines were not safe or
effective and they were seen as very
dangerous and scary vaccines were
demonized and my mom talked openly about
her beliefs that vaccines cause autism
brain damage and did not benefit the
health and safety of society I grew up
hearing these things and believing them
and it wasn't until I was older you know
16 17 - I started to develop the
critical thinking skills to understand
that that was not true once I turned 18
had the legal option to get those
vaccines and go against my mother um I'm
so on once I turned 18 and chose to do
that I made that decision despite the
objections my mom had and so for those
who followed my story this is fairly
redundant but for those that have it
that's all that happened I got the
vaccines that I was rejected and I
didn't have and I thought that would be
the end of my story I thought that I'd
get those vaccines I would develop that
immunity and that would be it but over
the course of a few months I started
doing interviews and then testified in
front of a US Senate committee after
that you know more interviews were
performed and I was even in Time
magazine and had the chance to share a
very concise message that vaccines were
safe and effective and that vaccines
work that was all it was there was a
simple platform it wasn't one that was
nuanced or complicated and it was one
coming from a teenager something that
was really important because
a lot of the scientific community is
from older individuals that are trying
to reach a younger generation and so
having a mature younger generation
representing their own and reaching them
is impactful it's important but my
message in my whole platform the reason
I was trying to spread this awareness
was it just about vaccines working but
also about misinformation and
misinformation when we hear it we think
about people like my mother who think
that vaccines cause autism that's the
Association we make but it's more
complicated than that misinformation
about vaccines can come in many forms
and it's not just about the side effects
there's misinformed ideas that there's
even a debate around vaccines that
there's a conversation at play where
both sides have equal footing that's not
true the the debate around vaccines is a
lot that's misinformation in itself the
science is decided vaccines are safe and
effective and so almost encouraging that
and legitimizing that idea is dangerous
in the same way that saying vaccines
cause autism is dangerous the science is
decided and it's fairly clear alongside
that there's also other misinformed
ideas that people that are misinformed
are bad people that my mom is a
malicious person which is not true she's
a loving mother if you think about it in
this way misinformation reaching people
and convincing them that vaccines cause
autism and brain damage when people
choose not to vaccinate they're doing
that for the same reasons that we speak
here today and people vaccinate their
children it's the concern of their
children's safety that's why they chose
not to vaccinate so my mom my mom chose
not to vaccinate and so clarifying that
having empathy and respect and
understanding is really important
because instead of demonizing the other
side and the misinformed individuals
that have fallen into this rabbit hole
you extend a hand and build bridges
instead of tearing them down at the same
time as well you need to understand that
misinformed people they are almost
victims to a disease that has
misinformation it's it's a sickness it
spreads in the same fashion that the
disease's we vaccinate against you it's
quick it reaches the vulnerable and it's
hard to stop and also people that become
sick from misinformation as disease of
misinformation
sometimes very hard to find a cure my
mother will probably never change her
views she will probably end up living in
her entire life up until her death bed
thinking that vaccines cause autism that
really never change and I have to
understand that in respect her and also
know that reaching my family my siblings
people that haven't made decisions yet
about vaccines it's gonna be more
important and trying to convince some
like my mother who's been led astray by
information for years it's almost like
prevention just like vaccines you have
to have an early intervention and the
way we do that is through education
systems strong medical industries and
having a strong budget and
representation and a community that
understands vaccines are important as
well as the legislators government
officials who defend science publicly
these are the things we need instead of
demonizing those are misinformed and
saying that they are the ones causing
these issues we need to find solutions
and it's fairly simple it's educating
those like myself a young teenager in
the middle of Ohio who had no idea what
vaccines did and because the CDC was
available to him and the debate show is
available to him it was it'll find out
that vaccines were safe and effective
making clear concise and medical
decision that's what we need to do and
that that's a message that is welcoming
it's it's a message that's encouraging
and kind and demonstrates the whole
motivation of the scientific community
the Simon tech community is not about
demonizing people is about helping them
and that's what we need to do thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much Ethan once
again a very brave young teenager who's
decided to go public with your concerns
your experience and a very strong
message for all of us another strong
message now we're privileged to have
Fergal and Kevin Brennan they're
brothers of Laura Brennan who very sadly
died in March 2019 and she was an
advocate for she's Irish and advocate
for HPV vaccines died of cervical cancer
in March this year and I think we also
have a video message from Laura so could
I ask the two brothers pleased to come
up here to the podium
good afternoon thank you to the w-h-o
and the Commission for inviting me here
today on behalf of my family I'm here
today to talk about how one girl the
voice of one girl can change everything
Laura passed away in March of this year
from cervical cancer a cancer that is
almost entirely preventable she was 26
years old she dedicated the last months
of her life to raising awareness of the
importance of the HPV vaccination she
did it because if she had the HPV
vaccine it's likely I would not be here
today she would be with us and silat
stranger to most she did it to spare out
the girls from suffering similar fate to
her own and suffering I'm from other
families from going to about we're going
to Laura was first diagnosed with
cervical cancer at the age of 24
following extensive treatment she
received the all-clear however a short
time later she got the news the cancer
had returned and this time was no longer
curable this was an ambitious determined
very clever young girl who would care
about a happy and successful career
she didn't dwell on it though she
quickly upset accepted her faith and
decided to pour all her energy whatever
she had left into campaigning for the
HPV vaccination the vaccine having been
celebrated when I was first introduced
in Ireland in 2010 with more than 90% of
girls being vaccinated had fallen to an
all-time low of 50 percent to 2017 this
was as a direct result of a
misinformation campaign which kick
started in Ireland four or five years
ago
parents became scared and began
declining the offers to get the young
girls vaccinated Laura sent a message to
the HSE the Irish Health Service in
September 2017
and offered to do anything she could to
assist in improving uptake rates in
Ireland the timing of this contact was
key to our success story the health
service at the time had just began the
first phase of an information campaign
and vaccine rates have begun to improve
when Laura became the face of the second
phase of the campaign she appeared on
the nation's flagship talk show the
nation took her to her heart and her
story began to change people's minds
about the vaccine
she became the very public face of the
reality of an unvaccinated girl from
then on she never missed an opportunity
to tell her story
knowing every time she did it had the
opportunity to save a life we were
overwhelmed with the effect Laura's
impact had she was awarded the first
ever patient advocacy medal by the Royal
Colleges of physicians Ireland's she
wanted volunteer Ireland's Awards she
won a night when she was honoured with
an honorary doctorate of literature from
University College Dublin and was named
Claire Person of the Year 2019 all these
honours they were great the meant a lot
to Laura but nothing mattered more to
her than object rights for the HPV
vaccine we know now Laura's story and
how was carefully told was exactly what
Ireland needed at the time just ten days
before she passed she was trilled to be
able to announce their country a twenty
percentage point increase in uptake to
70% this is a huge turnaround in an
18-month period when people heard Laura
speak R saw her on television they could
imagine her being their daughter their
sister their friends Laura gave this
horrible illness that was cervical
cancer that is cervical cancer a
powerful relatable and youthful face in
essence she was just an ordinary girl
facing death from a preventable illness
and that's one of the reasons she was
hired to ignore the good thing is that
the story of the HPV vaccine in Ireland
is a positive one more than 70 percent
the last years 12 and 13 year old girls
no vaccinators and our Minister for
health along with other political
parties they've now announced the
vaccine would be rolled out to boys in
this coming year right now in Ireland
the parents of 60,000 12 and 13 year
olds are making up their minds whether
they were consent to son or daughter
getting the HPV vaccine for many of them
Laura's story is ringing in their ears
her months of campaigning embedding her
story in Ireland and internationally and
around supporting parents to make the
choice that would protect our future
generations from HPV related cancers
Laura's campaigning letter becoming a
social media addict good or bad I don't
know she never seemed to have a phone
out of her head and social media though
as we know as a hotbed of vaccine
misinformation but it was also an
important pillar in the HPV vaccine
campaign led by
Irish Health Service and an aliens of
associated bodies and individuals on
social media we unfortunately have two
sets of messages can be colliding from
one hand the message supports by world
medical bodies and professionals the
vaccine is safe effective it will save
lives on the other hand misinformation
and mixed messages aims at confusing a
misinforming parents Laura never engaged
with anti vaccine sentiment online she
did read everything out there and she
happily engaged with everyone and anyone
who approached her looking for real
information advice or a listening ear
the vast majority have comes about her
work and contacts with her directly were
positive but she was attacked but the
negative ones show that we have some way
to go as a society to break down the
stigma that lingers of this deadly
cancer that is caused by a very common
virus in Ireland truth is finally
winning the parents are seeing past the
misinformation and getting their
information for a reputable and
trustworthy sources but we have more to
do to get rates back to the required
levels so how did iron reverse declining
HPV vaccine rates in an 18-month period
in short registers the medical community
political parity worked together towards
a joint goal getting the correct
information out there to parents became
prioritized and by having an ordinary
girl like Laura who used her voice and
her story for good was the secret
ingredient that changed the landscape
completely forever the extent of a reach
was phenomenal the hash tag that Irish
Health Service used to pay a tribute to
Laura after her passing has more than 15
million impressions on Twitter alone at
home and Ireland thousands of
celebrities and sports teams are now
wearing the HPV vaccine logo on their
jerseys and sports shirts in support of
Laura to increase awareness and the
vaccine and to increase awareness on the
HPV virus a documentary and Laura's
final months well they are national
television this coming week will also be
available online for the global audience
this was Laura's final major piece of
public work some might say a parting
gift also glamorous she now wanted to
let the general public see her at her
most weakest
she wanted to give that simple message
she was the reality of an unvaccinated
child parents can now protect
their son or daughter from going to the
same who could have imagined all this
would have come from a simple Facebook
message to the HSE just two years ago
working together we can eliminate HPV
related cancers within a generation
laura has passed the torch to us all our
family and it's our job to carry that
torch and shine a light on truth and
create a future for the next generation
that is free from her harmful strains of
HPV and the devastation that the cause
I'd like to thank you all for your time
today
patient advocates do make a key
difference and I'll leave you with a
short piece laura produced with the w
hit show this time last year thank you
very much my name is laura i was
diagnosed with cervical cancer stage 2b
in December 2016 and unfortunately it's
no longer curable if I had had the
vaccine I wouldn't be in the position I
am in today because the vaccine protects
against HPV 16 and HPV 16 caused by
cancer when I got my diagnosis I decided
that I would do anything to stop this
from happening to anyone else sometimes
when you hear about it cervical cancer
you don't actually think that could be
my daughter or that could be my friend I
am just your average 25 year old girl
and did happen to me as long as I'm
lucky to be here I will continue to
share the message to anyone that will
listen the HPV vaccine a safe and
effective and it is the best shield we
have to prevent this cancer from
happening
[Applause]
Thank You Laura Brennan not an ordinary
girl I have to say very moving story
thank you very much to the family for
coming here and speaking to us once
again Kevin from the heart thank you
thank you very much indeed
right we're going to move on seamlessly
to our second panel and this panel sorry
it is a very moving story so this for a
second let's pause for a second so we're
going to move on to our second panel
which is about the magic of